you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast emerging as the new gold
standard in quality and safety parallel
DNA based cannabis testing of multiple
microbes I'm Kristy dual of labyrinth
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminars brought
to you by labyrinth and sponsored by
pathogen DX pathogen DX delivers the
fastest easiest microbial testing
solutions to thwart microbial
contamination
for more information on our sponsor
please visit pathogen DX comm now let's
get started I would like to remind
everyone that today's event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and anytime you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the after question
box and click send at the top of your
screen you will also see a tab where you
can download white pages also please
notice you can share this webinar on
your personal social media just click on
that social sharing tab to let your
friends and colleagues know about
today's live event now if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
sound at the top right of your
presentation window or report your
problem by using that ask a question box
this presentation is educational and
this offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credit tab located at the top right of
your presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits I would
now like to introduce our two presenters
dr. Michael Hogan co-founder and chief
scientific officer at pathogen DXM
dr. Hogan's expertise is in the area of
physical chemistry bio sample processing
and genetic testing he is leading
multiple programs in technology
development at pathogen VX with special
emphasis on building its proprietary DNA
microarray technology into the cannabis
food safety and agricultural markets
also speaking today is dr. ben captain
principal scientist at pathogen VX dr.
Katzen leads the research and
development a sample preparation and
assay development for complete
biographies on dr. michael hogan and dr.
ben catchman please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen
dr. catchman you may now begin your
presentation
thank you very much for the introduction
my name is Ben Cashman principal
scientist of Pasadena TX and with me is
Michael Hogan chief scientific officer
and co-founder and will be presenting
this topic to you I'm splitting up the
presentation so during this during this
webinar
we'll be discussing different aspects of
microbial pathogen highlighting both
traditional practices as well as more
relevant molecular based practices
as an overview of what we're going to be
discussing during this presentation we
have four different topics Don't Ask
Don't Tell enriched or not enriched live
verse dead and then evaluation of
different molecular based technologies
focused on quand on PCR and quantitative
PCR don't-ask don't-tell will focus on
as the advent of molecular diet
diagnostic tools has come about such as
PCR and Eliza based assays we now have
the ability to test for specific
organisms that are either uncultured
bull or took weeks to identify the
ability to rapidly speciate presents a
shift in traditional microbial pasturing
detection away from the utilization of
broad class indicators that had
traditionally been used allowing for
better speciation more rapid results the
topic of in rich or natural rich is
going to focus on the process of
traditional fluid based enrichment which
is a traditional growth method that
allows for the selective or broad
enrichment of different microbial
organisms and has been utilized to
increase the sensitivity of traditional
culture based methods and while these
selective enrichments have tremendous
benefit the broad-based enrichers tend
to create bias and false negatives
within different diagnostics platforms
this will discuss the pros and cons of
enrichment in how newer molecular
methods have helped to shorten or even
fully eliminate the enrichment process
Mike will then just start to discuss
live versus dead and this is a
consistent criticism within different
molecular diagnostic platforms as
challenge of discriminating live versed
dead organisms so free-floating DNA or
viable vers non-viable versus live or
culturable cells and so Mike will
discuss during this presentation
different approaches that have been
published as well as a novel approach
for distinguishing viable and not viable
microorganisms last Mike will go into
different details in terms of the
different techniques quantitative PCR
and then endpoint PCR a couple different
detection based technologies such as
microarray or next-generation sequencing
so in terms of historical perspective
with different microbial based
diagnostic techniques plating or a
liquid based culture has really been the
gold standard for the past hundred and
thirty years and its really seen the
significant advance over that time
period in terms of the specificity of
the growth media's and the fluid as well
as plate based growth media's as well as
the enrichment conditions to identify
both specific and broad organisms and
while these advances have have led to
the identifications of thousands of
microbial organisms and helped to detect
and diagnose different pathogens during
outbreaks in food agriculture as well as
healthcare settings these advances are
are limited really based on the ability
to culture any of these organisms so if
you can't culture it you don't know
what's there this is kind of led to our
knowledge of current microbiology with
really less than 1% of the known
organisms being able to be cultured this
is a kind of restraint the industry and
kind of led to limitations within
different regulations because you can
only regulate which you can detect and
different regulations are based on
current diagnostic standards over the
past 30 or 40 years new molecular based
diagnostic platforms have really seen
significant advances in terms of
speciation being able to identify
numerous microorganisms at one time
without the need for tedious culturing
techniques or that or that high level
expertise that that a lot of traditional
micro biologists have in terms of
identifying specific cultures such as
led to a shift in in diagnostic
technologies and us being able to
identify that needle in a haystack with
greater speed accuracy and increased
sensitivity compared to traditional
plate plate based techniques
as an overview of these different
microbial diagnostic techniques we put
the other tables kind of break down some
of these techniques in terms of pros and
cons and kind of how we can move away
from some of these broad class
indicators into specific pathogen
detection so currently there's a wide
range of micro molecular biology tools
that are utilized for pathogen
diagnostics and they can be broken down
into three broad categories as shown on
the left under the technique column the
cell based techniques are really the
plate based techniques immunological
techniques are utilizing iliza platforms
or antibodies for detection and the
nucleic acid base techniques can be
broken down into a few different
categories really all based around
polymerase chain reaction and
modifications to to that to that basic
molecular biology technique cell based
techniques as I said are referring to
the liquid or solid media's that are
used to grow different organisms the
broad identification of this would be
for looking at total aerobic bacteria or
total yeast and mold or Selective
media's that can identify STEC positive
E coli or Salmonella enterica for
different Listeria organizers of the
more common pathogens and one of the
greatest advantages really this
technique is that's been tried and true
it's a reliable technique for the
organisms that are required to be
detected for different different
pathogens but it's timely time and
labor-intensive requiring high cost high
area in terms of what you're going to
need in turn to facilities as well as
you expertise in terms of being able to
to identify these specific organisms in
terms of the molecular techniques as I
said you have the ideological and
nucleic acid based techniques
the Eliza assays Musa logical methods in
which antibodies are developed to
specific identify a specific protein
generally on the cell surface of
different pathogens analyze offers the
ability for high-throughput qualitative
as well as quantitative results but can
suffer from moderate limits of detection
even with the advances of antibody
production you can see a lot of
significant lots a lot variability and
an increased cost with with the Eliza
technique compared to some other
molecular techniques nucleic acid-based
techniques are really based around the
advent of polymerase chain reaction or
PCR and either are broken down into
quantitative PCR to PCR which are going
to provide real-time cycling values or
endpoint PCR that's coupled to either
agarose gel DNA microarrays or
next-generation sequencing platforms for
the further detection part of it all
these nucleic acid based techniques
offer similar advantages such as high
sensitivity specificity and wrapping
rapid and easy to use platforms that are
amenable to high-throughput Diagnostics
each of the techniques has different
disadvantages and this is mainly based
around the lower limits of detection the
expertise and skills that are required
for different techniques as well and
over the next few slides we're going to
dive into a few of these molecular
techniques and break down the pros and
cons associated with both of them
so the first technique we're going to
look at is quantitative PCR technology
so quantitative PCR our to PCR is a very
elegant technique and provides very
sensitive and specific diagnostic
information for pathogen detection the
diagrams on the right cartoons on the
right are really looking at the two main
to PCR platforms cyber green and tack
man based PCR these different
modifications on each of these but as
these are two broad categories cyber
green is going to utilize primers and a
nonspecific dye that that will enter
chelate into a double-stranded DNA
during each round of amplification
releasing a fluorescent signal is going
to correlate with with amplification and
be able to give you real-time
information in terms of the organism
that that's being detected but it's not
specific in terms of the double-stranded
DNA that it's intercalating so if you
have off target effects that's not going
to be identified through savaging TaqMan
is a another quantitative PCR method in
which you're utilizing primers as well
as a complementary a specific probe for
your sequence there's different ways of
designing the probe but one method is
that as it's being extended the probe
will release and you'll have a distance
being separated from your floor for in
your quencher given a fluorescent signal
this provides increased specificity so
you can detect this visit organism of
interest and usually when you're looking
at multiplexing qpcr platforms you're
going to be using attack man based or
probe based massing well both of these
approaches are extremely useful they
have some significant challenges when it
comes to being multiplexed and usually
have challenges when it comes to
identifying very low limits of detection
such as 1cf you
so the current currently qPCR is limited
in terms of that multiplexing ability of
greater than four organisms and this is
really due to both an engineering as
well as the amount of reagent that can
be put into a tube if you have too many
primers and probes put into a tube you
can have significant off-target effects
with these they can really limit your
specificity and sensitivity of your
essay in terms of sensitivity to PCR can
be a sensitive assay but multiple
publications really highlight the lower
limit of detection of for CF use 250 CF
use and usually requires sample
enrichment meaning that the technique is
going to take at least an extra 24 to 72
hours to get a reliable result so
there's multiple companies out there
that make very good to PCR platforms and
are developing novel assays every day
the next technique we're going to talk
about is next-generation sequencing or
Sanger sequencing
sänger next generation sequencing have
really been a game changer in terms of
depth of knowledge and understanding
that we now have regarding the overall
microbiological landscape not only in
terms of our understanding of the total
amount of organisms present in the
sample but also in terms of genomic
sequence identification which has led to
greater specificity in terms of primer
and probe design understanding the
genomic content of an organism the
diagram on the right is depicting the
differences between Sanger sequencing
and next generation sequencing kind of
in broad terms
in the sequence identification both
platforms rely on endpoint pcr so in
that quantitative PCR but an endpoint
PCR platform followed by the detection
with either terminal nucleotides or
flowers or relabeled nucleotides that
will allow you to to either identify
your sequence in time or or use
algorithms to put your state your
sequence together so you can kind of
relate this back to performing a
standard PCR reaction and then
visualizing your PCR product on a grows
gel but with significantly better
sequence resolution in the field of
microbiome ik's in which are utilizing
primers to conserved regions such as the
16s if you're looking at bacteria or 18s
or i TS regions we were looking at funky
being able to design primers to some of
these conserved regions has allowed us
to gain a greater understanding of the
total amount of organisms that are
present or either cannabis or food
matrices and the table on the on the
left is from a recent publication in
which different strains of cannabis have
been subjected to broad fungal
sequencing either an 18s or i TS regions
and what you can really observe through
this kind of a case for moving away from
broad class indicators into more
specific diagnostic platforms and
identifying really the pathogenic
organisms of interest so what this
diagram is showing is for these
different strains of cannabis that have
been tested and the organisms identified
on the left you have broad
identification of different
non-pathogenic funky that would be
identified using the total yeast and
mold acid but will not provide
actionable diagnostic information to the
laboratory consumer and so again what
this really highlights is the need to
use specific platforms to identify
pathogens of interest rather than using
broad class indicators that don't
provide actionable information to
laboratories or consumers
the last technique we're going to talk
about is DNA or RNA microarrays
DNA RNA microarrays art has been around
for a while but in terms of being
utilized as a diagnostic platform have
really have really turned around in the
past past five to ten years so DNA RNA
microwaves are another tool that's
similar to next generation sequencing in
which endpoint PCR is coupled to the DNA
microarray for sensitive and specific
identification of multiple organisms at
one time overall the DNA microarrays are
similar to tapman PCR which are
designing primers and probes to an
organism interest rather than everything
being in a single master mix the primers
and probes are separated and the probes
the single-stranded DNA probes are
deposited on the surface of the glass
microscope slide or microarray and the
separation of these primers and probes
allows for greater multiplexing and
fewer off target effects leading to
faster and more reliable speciation so
looking at the diagram that's depicted
here on the screen it's a very standard
process similar to any PCR based
technique where you're going to extract
your DNA use different strategies to
increase your sensitivity of the assay
here we use a dual PCR reaction to
increase the sensitivity RF that have a
floor for to to our assay which will be
used for detection once that's amplified
the complementary single-stranded DNA
probes will hybridize to your PCR and
labeling product and you'll be able to
scan your slide and pick up the
fluorescence signal telling you
something's positive or negative within
your slide
as an example of this patent MDX has
made numerous microarrays two different
micro arrays that are out on the market
is a detect X and quantex in microarray
and they both allow for multiplex
detection of multiple bacterial
pathogenic and non-pathogenic so that
you distinguish those as well as
multiple pathogenic fungal organism set
of interests in the cannabis market as
well as quantitative assays looking at
some of the broad class indicators so
with with different micro arrays you can
start to put together tools to meet all
the different markets within the United
States
this kind of as a conclusion to this you
know
traditional pleat based methods have
been around for a long time they really
don't meet the current demands of the
market right now both in food
agriculture in the medical space this is
really in terms of the pace of research
the pace of Diagnostics that are
required nowadays in the ability to
identify multiple pathogenic organisms
that are really not culturable so if
some of these improve specificities was
multiple molecular techniques that are
available to consumer in which they can
mix and match different techniques to
get the sensitivity and specificity they
need to meet the diagnostic demands
whatever industry learning
the next topic that I'm going to go into
is topic of enrichment and basically
enriched to enrich or not to enrich your
your sample of interest so in Richmond
is a fairly standard technique and
microbiology and food agriculture in
which you can use selective media's or
broad media's to enrich a specific
organism interest or broadly enriched
organisms and for decades and enrichment
has really been used as a way to
increase the sensitivity and robustness
of different assays in which they
couldn't get down to saving one CFU per
gram detection level that other assays
are requiring so it's really a tool has
been used to increase the sensitivity of
different techniques such as
quantitative PCR or plate based
techniques but the question is rarely
asked you know does enrichment truly
amplify all all microorganisms present
in the sample and even even pace and the
answer is really no to that question I
think that that's not really debated
answered but we'll provide some data to
back that up
and really the reason for this is that
within each sample you're going to have
different inhibitors you're going to
have different different growth rates of
different organisms and organisms that
grow better in different media's and
you're going to get what's called vision
what's called enrichment bias on some of
these samples and what that can lead to
is is false negatives within your sample
and so with the advent of a lot of
different molecular detection platforms
we've been able to improve the
sensitivity of the assay where you no
longer are required to do enrichment for
every single platform and you can get a
realistic snapshot of the true
pathogenic content of your of your
sample of interest before enriched both
speeding up your platform and improving
the sensitivity of your essay at the
same time
so as an example there's numerous
publications that dive into the question
of enrichment bias in different in
different platforms two of the
publications that were highlighted here
from Dunbar Idol and Petit Gil at all
and both are utilizing sequencing as a
way to identify enrichment bias within
the population compared to a unenriched
sample so both are showing very similar
results in and really what this is
showing is that as you enrich a sample
you're actually getting less diversity
out of your sample so you will have a
sample that will start out with say 50
organisms as you start to enrich your
sample you're going to see a decrease in
those organisms so you're going to see a
shift in a part of the population of
your organisms where say e coli is going
to out-compete to say Listeria for
resources and you might get a false
negative result where Listeria is
actually present in your sample but
you're not able to detect it because
because it's been killed during the
process of enrichment it's kind of a
broad example of how enrichment bias can
occur and how it can lead to false
negatives within your sample
you
this industry this this hasn't really
been explored as much and it's an
ongoing work in progress for us and
which we've taken a stab at looking at
different Universal enrichment media's
that have been commonplace within the
industry kind of this mist surrounding
Universal Richard media's and in that
and that they're all fine and
everything's going to going to enrich
evenly the two graphs on the right are
looking at a few different enrichment
media's and looking at using
next-generation sequencing for different
primary regions within I TS and 18s
really to take takeaway message from
looking at these graphs and looking at
the different enrichment enrichment
conditions from 0 to 72 hours is that
the population shift dramatically
depending on the enrichment media that
you're using and this is really causing
an uneven and bias enrichment in which
you really aren't able to predict which
organisms are going to come out on top
depending on the starting population and
so really leading to a challenge in the
industry of weathers and you know
enrichment is is beneficial or hindrance
in terms of identifying pathogens of
interest
kind of as a conclusion to this there
are techniques out there that can work
without without the need for sample
enrichment and by being creative in
utilizing different molecular based
approaches you can really increase the
sensitivity of grassing without the need
to perform sample in Richmond really
getting a true picture of the pathogenic
content within your starting sample and
really starting to dive into what is
actually pathogenic and moving away from
these broad class indicators that really
provide no actionable information and so
now I'm going to turn the presentation
over to Mike thank you very much what
I'm going to talk about is two things as
Ben had discussed in the beginning I
first going to describe I think some
very interesting work that's been done
by others and then some by our own labs
to try to address this idea of focusing
in in the course of a nucleic acid based
test on only live cells in mixtures of
live plus dead though the reason for
this is both this is related to both a
strength and a weakness of nucleic acid
testing everybody knows about physical
anthropology where people you know one
does DNA testing on teeth and bones and
long-dead issues human forensic science
of DNA found as residue on you know
shoes and surfaces can be used to human
identification that's a big strength and
in the area of microbial analysis not in
the necessarily in the case of cannabis
enviromental screening bio metal testing
it's very useful to be able to track the
disposition of airborne bacteria and
fungi onto surfaces they may not be
culturable anymore they may be dead
because of desiccation but it's
important to track them
but in the particular case of of
cannabis and hemp the state regulations
are very specific about really trying to
resolve the difference between you know
culturable contaminations live cells on
plant matter and previously live cells
dead dead material
PCR is very powerful tool in the sense
that the degraded nucleic acid even
though it may be in a dead cell even
though it may be reduced to very small
fragments can be PCR amplified and
detected almost as well as as is the
case with the DNA is to extract it from
a viable cell so the question is how can
you or can you modify PCR based methods
whether it's 2pq PCR or endpoint PCR
methods of the sort that then had
discussed can you modify it so as to be
able to focus in on the live cell
fraction for several years now there's
been some really elegant dye based
methods that have been developed to do
this and they're they're either based on
staining of cells that is you know the
apply a a fluorescent dye that would be
taken in up into dead cells but are
generally protected from uptake in a
living cell and you can simply count you
know so things like back back light and
trip on blue and so forth can
distinguish live versus dead cells based
upon which you know take up the dyes in
which do not preps more interesting in
the context of nucleic acid analysis
qPCR microarrays sequencing and so forth
has been a very interesting observations
that things derive from Atheneum bromide
either Ophidian mono a site or propidium
mono aids that they're both a lot like
kopitiam have an interesting properties
they are also rejected from up cake into
cells is the case for the two cell
biology stains but they they are photo
chemically reactive and then wherever
they may be whether it's in the cellular
debris floating about in solution or or
if they do get into cells the the the
fact is that the dyes binds to DNA and
upon a radiation will become covalently
linked as a DNA molecule and inhibit its
ability to support PCR and any any other
analysis that would happen thereafter
so as we'll show you in the next slide
some very nice data from from the use of
though
we've there are maybe a couple of minor
weaknesses to be considered in the use
of these dyes number one they haven't
really been validated for the use for
use of funghi because at this
distinction between live versus dead
which is very nice for the these things
like propidium mono azide is not quite
so robust when it comes to the
distinction of live versus dead funghi
and it also involves some somewhat
somewhat somewhat tedious steps of
having to irradiate the samples under
intense light what I'll talk about that
after that is some physical methods that
we begin to investigate that may object
some of those problems and then this
slide simply shows summarizes you know
it's been a number of very nice studies
but what is shown here is basically on
the left is a you know basically you
know live Bible versus Dead revival
versus dead and you can see we're not
going into detail is that and this is
assessed by qpcr that when you have you
know live cells and then heat killed
cells mixed together or independently
you can get a very nice sort of 5cq
shift in qPCR which corresponds to more
than a 10 fold distinction between live
versus dead using propidium azide which
is which is actually you know very nice
behavior but again the question being is
there is a way to do this using methods
that don't involve photochemistry and
perhaps might be a bit more appropriate
for fungal contaminants as well as
bacterial what we begin to our cells in
our own labs have begun to take
advantage of simple centrifugation just
benchtop centrifugation like everybody
runs in a micro lab or in molecular
biology and part of it's because of the
processing that we do ourselves in our
own nucleic acid test which starts out
with a simple centrifugation to harvest
cellular material whether love you know
from culture or from extracted from
from cannabis or him to form a pellet
and if you go back and look at the
literature which is summarized in broad
terms here it points out that as
everyone knows that bacteria and fungi
generally speaking sediment quite
rapidly under ordinary conditions
benchtop centrifugation 4000 G's to form
nice pellets the the yes is marked in
green and also perhaps obvious enough
but nevertheless the fact of the matter
is that you know upon cellular
disruption the resulting genomic DNA
even if it isn't fragmented whole
bacterial genomes and even whole fungal
genomes don't sediment to form very very
well to form pellets although as you'll
see the fungal genomes being quite a bit
larger and relatively tight contact with
protein will left to their own devices
not sediment you know quite so and with
ins quite such crisp distinction
relative to cells on their own so what
we have chosen to do is to say well
let's see what happens when we use as a
first line of defense
the pelleting of cells of live versus
dead and then augment that that simple
physical separation by biochemical
enrichment and by biochemical enrichment
we refer to simple biochemical
treatments that would tend to degrade
nucleic acid material generally but the
agents that are being used much as was
described for the use of these hub dyes
don't penetrate into intact cell so what
we have what is described in brokens
rather detail terms on this slide is a
protocol that will that we have come to
use ourselves that will be used as we
used as the basis for data I'll try to
throw in the next slide which is simple
and that is
take cells in suspension bacteria or
yeast funghi a an easy way to generate a
match to preparation of dead cells is to
just heat them because even you know a
relatively short duration heating near
the boiling point will kill both
bacteria and fungi to make match samples
so you got live ones that weren't heated
dead ones that were heated then what we
will show and is proven to be very
practical is this idea you know spin
them to make a pellet and one will see
that there is for the case of bacteria a
reasonably good separation between live
and dead upon spinning in the case of
fungi some separation but not
particularly good separation followed by
a biochemical enrichment step take the
pellet thus produced by the centrifugal
treat it briefly with you know a
cocktail to 30 or 37 centigrade to
degrade the extra cellular dead nucleic
acid under conditions where the cellular
nucleic acid is protected from the
biochemistry data of that kind is shown
on the next slide on the Left what one
sees is is kind of matched live versus
dead pairing for brewers yeast and on
the right as an example of fungal that
discrimination of live versus dead and
on the right is Salmonella enterica
bacterial but to point out you know
parallel all the same protocol by the
way the same centered centrifugation the
same subsequent biochemical treatment so
first with the on the right with the
Salmonella the the black bars correspond
to the outcome of treatment of live
cells viable cells that have not been
killed and the white bars correspond to
dead the data are on that y-axis our
fluorescence units this is this data
happens to have been obtained from
microarray analysis but one would have
attained similar data if one would it
have done qPCR and what you see is that
on the right is that in the
physical part of that graph that refers
to said sedimentation only so the heat
treated bacteria one can see that in
fact you know really only a relatively
small fraction of them of the dead cells
spin down to form a pellet and thus a
good discrimination of versus live
versus dead with physical enrichment
only and one sees that if one goes
through the same process but after that
engage in the biochemical enrichment
there's an additional in you know did
you know
discrimination such that the distinction
between live and dead for the Salmonella
after biochemical enrichment is is
almost is almost perfect more than a
factor of ten more like a factor forty
discrimination as I mentioned
funky generally speaking because their
genomes are rather large and in tight
association with histones simple center
get centrifugal enrichment is not quite
so good so the leftmost part of the left
panel under Brewer G's you can see that
pelleting alone does provide for a
modest amount of enrichment that is not
maybe there's a 50% enrichment of or
depletion of the yeast in the pellets
formed in the dead samples but it's you
know not really much acceptable there
you can see that in the rightmost part
of that panel you can see the power of
it in a sense that those pellets
generated physically upon retreatment
with biochemical and reagent just 15
minutes and 37 degrees you can see that
other becomes there's a substantial
additional discrimination there's no
loss essentially of the live cells upon
the subsequent biochemical treatment and
and the dead cell fraction has reduced
pretty much to background so again this
is quite very keen to pursue what maybe
perhaps improvements of this the kinds
of improvements that make good sense is
that this kind of work as many of you
may know was kind of naturally suited
for coupling to remediation studies or
property of remediation that's ongoing
that is you know vaporous hydrogen
peroxide and other methods that may be
used to sterilize cannabis and and/or
hemp and so we're presently
collaborating with a number of groups
have very nice ways of generating such
sterilizations then using these tools to
to confirm and quantify the the level of
sterilization that has occurred by those
physical sterilization methods
so conclusions I looks like based upon
what's been done already the very nice
dye based work that others have done the
the mixed physical and biochemical work
that we're currently doing and continue
to do it looks as though a number of
tools are emerging to allow PCR based
methods to do a much better job of
distinguishing viable the viable cell
fraction versus the dead cell fraction
and in any number of contexts cannabis
and have being an obvious one of
importance to the present group but also
environmental screening and so on now in
the next and final part of the talk I'm
going to revisit a bit of what Ben had
talked about in terms of the to sort of
principal classes of PCR based nucleic
acid analysis real-time PCR qPCR such as
tack man and then methods that are fall
into the category that Ben had described
of endpoint PCR that is where the as I
will show in the next slide where the
PCR reaction has been allowed to go very
close to completion and at that time
additional methods are used to
interrogate the product of that endpoint
ECR and now those methods can be
capillary electrophoresis which is the
basis for almost all human
identification for instance and then
also some microbial identification
methods next-generation sequencing and
microarray analysis the qPCR methods are
as Ben had mentioned have a great
strength they're sort of one pod
analysis they're very elegant and are
quite well suited for doing type you
know screening of a large number of
samples if you're not interested in
looking for too many different microbes
at the same time sequencing is also
quite has great power has great
resolution and and as does the ability
to interrogate the microbial content by
micro arrays but the methods all have
their own weak
this is to PCR is not very as bedhead
mentioned is poor at multiplexing if
you're multiply month of multiplexing
you mean interrogating many microbes at
the same time sequencing is much better
at that but it does involve a lot more
sample preparation you need multiple
devices
same thing with microarrays historically
the sample prep and analysis was much
more complex and not perhaps well suited
for you know high-throughput testing but
that has and has changed in the recent
years as Ben mentioned this is probably
one of the more important graphs that
you're going to have a take-home message
to think about at the end of this
discussion the standard picture of the
so-called s-shaped curves that one
obtains during regular PCR reactions
again so this is where when the y-axis
here refers to the amount of amplified
DNA product is produced upon PCR and the
x-axis refers to the number of cycles of
heating and cooling the number of cycles
of PCR qPCR real-time PCR the key piece
of information of importance happens
very early in that reaction that's the
red arrow on this graph and that's the
point where the amount of product just
emerges as being distinguishable from
the background around it it's very
useful parameter if you're doing your
kind of quantify the nucleic acid
content of samples
the reason being that if there's more
DNA to start with that point of
inflection will be moved to the left
that there's less DNA in the original
sample that point of inflection called
CQ will move to the right so it's a very
nice way to get some quantitative
information on a relatively simple
sample near the end of the reaction the
end point which is identified by the
green arrow
very little direct information about
quantitation that can be obtained from
that because sooner or later most
samples will converge to more or less
the same PCR endpoint however the
interesting attribute of that endpoint
is that number one as is obvious there's
an awful lot more DNA in the specimen
near the endpoint of the reaction
relative to the beginning when the qPCR
data would have been obtained
and and secondly if done correctly of
that abundant sample can be fed into
other methods like capillary
electrophoresis of the sort used for
human identification next-gen sequencing
microarrays and so forth
from which very interesting data can be
obtained I'll we'll talk about that a
second here the practical value of that
at low resolution is shown in this table
the first few rows are the various types
of sort of general endpoint PCR methods
it been discussed then I've discussed a
bit more PC are coupled to
next-generation sequencing which is the
basis for the whole field of what people
called microbiome ik said is the study
of the distribution of microbes in and
not just cannabis and hemp plant matter
generally human health and so forth and
in those studies it's very well known
that because
the first step in that process is
endpoint PCR is quite routine to be able
to interrogate the content of a single
genome one cells worth of nucleic acid
at the time
similarly PCR coupled the capillary
electrophoresis which happens to be them
the basis for all human identification
but at nimman recent work has been also
used for fungal detection again is quite
capable in coupling PCR to the methods
of capillary electrophoresis to detect
single genomes worth of nucleic acid in
a single test
similarly PCR coupled to microarray
analysis again because it has the same
end point PCR reaction the beginning has
quite cleanly clearly capable of at
detecting and analyzing the contents of
one genomes worth of nucleic acid and as
Ben had mentioned earlier and is
actually quite well known from the
literature that because the key
information to be obtained by Q PCR has
obtained early on in the PCR reaction
the so called CQ value the limits of
resolution are a bit reduced because you
have to live with what you've gotten
early in their reaction relative to late
and so it's somewhere between one order
of magnitude or a bit higher you know
bit lower resolution that is you can't
see a single genomes worth of nucleic
acid in P and Q PCR generally speaking
and generally requires 10 or perhaps
more times nucleic acid than that and
that's right as Ben had mentioned that's
a non-trivial matter because many of the
regulations in cannabis and have call
out for the ability to distinguish the
presence or absence of single colony
forming units in a gram let's say of
material which means you have to be able
to analyze exceedingly load numbers of
genome equivalents in a specimen unless
you enrich and so as Ben mentioned the
qPCR methods are very often coupled to
enrichment in order to amplify the
amount of you know in flu
suspension culture the amount of
microbial contamination to get it up to
the few tens of genome equivalents per
PCR level
i'ma show here again all those it's a
complicated slide I think is a very
useful one that sort of sort of
summarizes I think the very interesting
attributes of endpoint PCR in this case
coupled to microarray analysis and so
what's shown on this slide is is a
series of doping expose doping
experiments where purified nucleic acid
from Aspergillus Niger or purified
nucleic acid from flavahz or fumigatus
or TRAI s-- is introduced into an end
point PCR reaction and subsequent to
that reaction in this particular case
isn't is analyzed by microarray analysis
of the sorts that we we do but you would
have gotten somewhat similar generalife
results from next-gen sequencing or from
capillary electrophoresis and what is
seen in the red boxes that probably the
most important thing is to first look at
the topmost row which refers to a
hundred thousand genome equivalents of
nucleic acid put into a single PCR
reaction as one would imagine it's it's
easy to detect that but what's important
and in this particular case let's say
Aspergillus Niger was introduced and in
the column of analysis for Aspergillus
Niger there's obviously an awful lot of
signal in this case it's fluorescent
signal coming off the microarray but
what's interesting is that in the
closely related
you know analysis that's occurring in
the same array there's indistinguishably
low levels of cross contamination with
flava store Freema goddess or Korea's if
you move down to the bottom of that
graph it's corresponds to the analysis
of flavors under the same conditions and
the flavors now becomes easy to see
immeasurably low levels of fake cross
analysis with respect to the other
closely related Aspergillus and so on
with respect to Fuma goddess and turay
us so
points out again the top row and each
one of those four quadrants points out
something is very important that if done
correctly it's not unique specifically
to microwaves but microwaves are good at
this by uncoupling that PCR
amplification reaction to be a
subsequent analysis one can get very
good specificity so here with where you
know a hundred thousand genome copies in
the PCR reaction you over in fact
overwhelmed in the entire system and yet
there's really almost no you know fake
cross analysis you cleanly can identify
when you put in Niger you see Niger when
you put in flavors you put in flavors
and so forth the other interesting
landmark at the bottom of each one of
these is what happens when in fact
you're only introducing one genome
equivalent into each PCR reaction and
then amplifying up endpoint PCR and then
doing the microarray analysis at the end
notice that the data looks surprisingly
similar in the sense that the one genome
equivalent if you look at the bottom of
each one of those four boxes the one
genome equivalent produces an abundant
fluorescence signal after hybridization
for the microarray has been described it
yet no measurable cross hybridization to
any of the alt closely related
alternatives when you put in one genome
copy of Niger you get a big signal you
don't get any signals for prim flavors
from the god Astraeus when you put in
one genome copy of flavas etc you don't
get cost hybridization points out a very
interesting attribute of of end point
PCR coupled to other methods but most
particularly to microarrays it gives you
the ability to very often in analytical
chemistry or analytical microbiology you
have a situation where you say well you
might have great sensitivity but in the
limit of let's say you know vanishingly
small quantities of input material like
one genome you won't have much you know
then you must have much specificity that
is you know it you know how can you have
both very things that tend to be very
sensitive tend to be very nonspecific
and conversely things that tend to be
very specific tend to be relatively you
know insensitive and you can see that in
fact that's not so here so the take-home
message which has been seen by us than
by others is that one number one the
lower limit of detection for endpoint
PCR followed by something like
microarrays is easily at or below one
genome equivalent for reaction and if
you sniff done correctly can generate
data of that kind that are extremely
specific not just one this there's a
tiny amount of specimen in the sample
but when in this particular case you've
introduced ten to the fifth times more
material so very nice capacity to
resolve things at the limits of almost a
theoretical limit of sensitivity and so
really just to finish up I think this
part of it again kind of a take-home
message to think about is that in
evaluating the you know the pluses and
minuses of real-time PCR and versus
endpoint PCR methods you know real-time
PCR is is you know very practical it's
elegant but generally speaking the lower
limits of detection are in the 10 - you
know perhaps one or two dozen genome
equivalents per assay endpoint PCR
methods like microarrays and capillary
electrophoresis next-gen sequencing can
routinely obtain of one genome
equivalent you know sensitivity that one
genome equivalent per protest and under
conditions were in fact the specificity
of what you're detecting it can be very
very high that is the ability to resolve
cleanly the difference between closely
related materials
and with that I just want to I guess sum
up thank you very much for your interest
and will now open the discussion open to
questions thank you
dr. Hogan dr. Cashman thank you for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of our
webinar now to our audience if you have
a question you'd like to ask please do
so now just click on that ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen and we will answer as many of
your questions as we have time for so
let's get started ok gentlemen our first
question some microorganisms are
notoriously difficult to life is there a
DNA extraction component to the testing
workflow
yes in the sorts of analysis that we
have shown particularly in the context
of the LIBOR is dead but generally
speaking and all of the work that we do
ourselves the work flow is as we sort of
as I sort of alluded to quickly is to
generate a pellet and that pellet as I
agree with the person who asked the
question must be opened up in order to
be analyzed and so the routine aspect of
what happens thereafter is that we we do
an extremely robust lysis part of our
kit and I think a valuable aspect of the
technology that we've developed is we
can make such a pallet license under it
temperature under conditions that are
extremely caustic can release the DNA
compliment of bacteria and fungi into a
very small volume and then what we do to
it after that again is kind of our
approach to things is that we neutralize
we have ways of neutralizing that lysis
solution which then gets used
straightaway for PCR so we agree that
obviously you must release the nucleic
acid from especially from fungal spores
bacterial spores and so forth but we do
so in such a way that is both robust but
can be neutralized and then used as a
very small volume and that's one of the
reasons we we can we can keep
concentrated the microbial samples that
we are isolating and analyzing
thank you our next question does your
definition of live cells include viable
but non culturable
yeah so you know molecular methods are
able to detect and amplify viable but
not culturable cells one of the
distinctions between plate culturing and
different molecular approaches so that's
one reason why we've spent a lot of time
trying to differentiate between my first
ed so that we could start to answer that
question of you know are we amplifying
viable but non culturable cells and
excluding dead cells
attachment our next question is it
possible that the chemical treatment of
cells can cause more cell death and in
consequence a change in the outcome
that gets token here in I guess
interpreted in the following way and
that is the chemical treatments of cells
that that are done analytically almost
certain for instance in the case of
propidium mono azide frankly is almost
certain that in the case of using such
photochemistry
the previously live cells that would be
treated by PMA will be killed they will
remain physically intact so that the
nucleic acid in them can be can be
recovered but the in those cases the the
chemical treatment to distinguish live
versus dead almost certainly although
keeping the live cells intact will kill
them but it's the next step in that
process is not to culture them in any
case it's to extract them they harvest
the nucleic acid from those those
treated cells the case of the in our
case or the combination of physical and
biochemical treatment it's a little bit
different actually the physical
treatment the formation of pellets
retains viability and although we
haven't spent a great deal of time
studying at the biochemical enrichment
that we there do thereafter probably
retains viability in most cases but we
have not really characterized that
because again our primary interest is to
is to take the cells obtain thereafter
and then go through this process of
lysine that I just discussed in my
previous response and so on so but
generally speaking that these live
versus dead treatments are mostly you
know up until now have been generally uh
studied and optimizing the content of
quickly this straight away extracting
the nucleic acid from the resulting life
cell fraction and not worrying too much
about whether the chemical treatments
had altered viability
Thank You dr. Hogan
what do you mean by endpoint PCR is it
basic PCR with detection of signal by
electrophoresis or a regular PC are
coupled to the seee microarrays and GS
etc
let's open here I think it's all it's a
general class and again it refers to the
course of the reaction and that is PCR
is self-limiting reactions all PCR
reactions will ultimately slow down and
reach a plateau at the end and it's that
act of forming the plateau at the end
where you produced as much nucleic acid
as you're going to and the reaction has
either become as has it has stopped
because I've you've depleted one or more
of the reagents and the PCR reaction but
actually most of the time it's due to
its endpoint its product inhibition the
production of the amplicons themselves
and and or inorganic phosphate produced
during the the enzymatic reaction you
know tends to slow to or shut down the
reaction it's the act of reaching that
that plateau point that that is the
endpoint of PCR thereafter the the
product that reaction can be analyzed in
any any way one chooses whether it's
capillary electrophoresis or next-gen
sequencing or microarrays and they all
would become then having been having
tapped into the endpoint of the PCR
reaction that had preceded them would
become a type of endpoint PCR
thank you can you briefly address how
pathogen DX's platform also avoids false
positives as false positives can also
have a significant impact on cannabis
workflow
yeah this is been so full I mean both
positives are really referring to
specificity of the essay and I was kind
of depicted and one of Mike's slides
when he's looking at the four different
Aspergillus and how we are looking at
them so you know just using that as an
example those four Aspergillus have very
very similar sequences and so being able
to design specific probes that can
interrogate unique regions of the genome
is one method that we use to to
eliminate false positives from assay we
also have a we perform two different PCR
reactions within ours that utilized for
different primer pairs that also bind to
unique recent regions so we have a few
different strategies in which we're able
to eliminate false false positives and
improve the specificity of our assay
thank you now can you share what is the
total time to result for this process
the PCR plash microarray sure so from
from start to finish it's about six to
eight hours designed to try to be
completed within a single single workday
once you're you're trained and
proficient at TSA you can run about a
hundred samples in a single day with one
technician with the SA so two designed
to be completed in six to eight hours
from sample prep all the way through
getting your results thank you gentlemen
would you be able to talk us through a
timeline for sample prep and sample run
time to get an idea of how much labor we
need to run these tests yeah sure so
I'll try to break this down as much as I
can
so most of labor is on the front end of
usually with the sample prep and then
the low side reaction so we perform
sample preparation followed by a low
side PCR reaction which is basically an
enrichment PCR followed by a labeling
PCR where you're going to be adding your
floor for to your gear amplicon of
interest and then you're going to after
you have your labeling product you're
going to hybridize that onto your DNA
microarray once that's done you're going
to take the scanned results and you're
going to upload that into the augury
software to get your results out so the
most hands-on time is during the sample
preparation step once you're done with
the sample preparation step which takes
about an hour and 15 minutes hour and 30
minutes give or take then the rest of
steps are really just loading your
96-well plate to perform PCR and
basically after your loci step you're
just using a multi-channel pipette to
complete the rest of the steps most of
the time is actually downtime either
during incubation or during the PCR
process
thank you dr. catchments can you explain
the lo-fi PCR and labeling PCR reaction
and why is dual PCR needed sure so low
side PCR is kind of our answer to sample
enrichment but we're doing specific
sample enrichment using primers that are
designed for organisms of interest all
we're really doing is taking advantage
of the natural process of PCR to
basically put it on steroids so we're
doing back-to-back PCR reactions and
that really drives up the sensitivity of
our assay so for example if you have a
one CFU or very low limit of detection
very low level of an organism present in
your sample during the low size step
that steps really designed to try to
amplify that specific organism to a
range where when you start your labeling
PCR step it's going to amplify earlier
the PCR cycle and improve your
sensitivity the low-side PCR step is
just normal PCR there's nothing special
about it it's just a multiplex PCR
reaction the labeling PCR is a nested
bias PCR reaction we have nested primers
inside your low side product and then
one of those primers is put in an
abundance and that primer has a floor
for conjugated to it so the benefit of
that is when you're finished with your
labeling PCR reaction you're going to
have a pool of single-stranded DNA that
has your floor four already conjugated
to it and you go directly the
hybridization
now we have time for a few more
questions but I just want to remind our
audience that those questions we are
unable to answer today and that and
those that come in during the on demand
period will be answered by our speakers
via the email address you provided at
the time of registration okay let's
continue our next question is
centrifugation part of your workflow
yeah so centrifugation is a key part of
our sample preparation workflow so once
you have a sample in you know in
cannabis industry right now you're going
to weigh out a gram of sample you're
going to add nine mils of PBS or some
type of broth you're going to vortex
that and then you're going to take out
one mil of that and perform two
sequential centrifugation steps the
first one is a slower speed that's meant
to pellet some of the bulk material and
remove some potential PCR inhibitors say
from flower samples it's really
important when you're working with
edibles and flower samples to kind of
pellet that bulk material then you're
going to transfer the supernatant to a
clean micro centrifuge tube and then the
second century d--ation step is where
you're going to be pelleting your
microorganisms of interest so that's a
faster spin at 14,000 GS the century
geisha steps also helped to eliminate
all of the free-floating and a good
majority of the dead cells as you can
see depends on the organism how well
that gets taken care of but that that's
the benefit of the two centrifugation
steps from there you just performing
normal you're just performing the normal
sample digestion process
thank you now when screening first ecchi
coli we look for s 2 X 1 and s 6 2 genes
what are your thoughts on dormant genes
such as e AE
um that's a good question we we actually
we haven't done much with ei e jeans we
really just designed this based on the
regulations that are that are out there
in the cannabis industry so we we have
looked into designing primers and probes
to that but it just hasn't been
something we've we put on the array
thank you are there predominant
pathogens in those samples and how many
are needed to control losses
um so in terms of cannabis flowers just
use that as an example there's
predominant like predominant pathogens
really on the fungal side you don't
often see a lot of Salmonella e.coli in
flower samples naturally-occurring
usually see that from contamination from
somebody who's doing the trimming
basically people not washing their hands
and not having a clean work environment
but if you look through some of the
papers you can look through the
sequencing on on one of the slides that
I presented you can see that you know
there's a broad spectrum of different
fungal pathogens that are present in
most cannabis samples Aspergillus
probably be in the one of most concern
but there's also certain Penicillium
strains that might be of interest
thank you dr. catchman few more we can
squeeze in here how do you calculate
genome copy number is it by
concentration so we calculate so when
we're calculating genome copy number
that's usually using purified genomic
DNA to try to back calculate or what we
would estimate the CFU would be so we're
looking at the total size of the genome
as well as the copies per cell and for
this we can share kind of our
calculations with them if they're so
curious
very good thank you where does Oh God I
was going to say that anyone who's
interested in can access our website one
of our tests is called quad and it is
based upon in the course of in the
course of performing the kandan the
two-step PCR that Ben had mentioned we
introduced internal quantitative
standards such that they amplify they
are virtually identical to the regions
of interest that are being that are the
basis for the sequence variability that
one can use for speciation ninety-five
percent identical they are amplified at
the same time and because we can do this
readily at time of microarray analysis
they are available to be hybridized to
their own sequence specific probe spots
on the array in parallel with the the
amplified bacterial or fungal complement
that is in the sample and then by direct
reference Ben had said by direct
referencing internally of of the signal
obtained from the unknown sample to the
internal reference sample we can obtain
the which is known in terms of the
number of copies per reaction we can
obtain the relative number of nucleic
acid copies in the unknown
thank you now well we're almost out of
time so let's wrap with this final
question one of the hurdles we face here
in Hawaii
utilizing pathogen DX for compliance
testing is convincing our clients the
reliability and consistency that
pathogen VX can provide a huge concern
is convincing our clients that a
positive that is detected detected is
not a false positive could you briefly
reiterate how your product has
invalidated by other independent
entities for other state departments of
Health also is there any other
information that you can reiterate on
how your product minimizes false
positives
sure but a lot of information for that
question
so we've done a number of different
validation studies either internally or
externally with with partner labs to try
to ensure the reproducibility of our
assay when you're looking at two
different two different assays when
you're looking at detect assays versus
quantitative assays you're looking at
different standard deviations I think a
big problem overall though in the
industry for most industries is
basically as we switch from plate based
methods or visual methods of detection
to molecular methods there's a
difference in the sensitivity and
specificity of the assay molecular
methods are usually going to provide a
higher sensitivity and and greater
specificity than some of the plate based
methods and I think that's been kind of
driving a lot of the conversation lately
in terms of people thinking that it's a
false positive when it's actually
something present in the sample and a
molecular method is just able to pull
that needle out of the haystack a little
bit better a lot of our papers are on
our website
and we can provide additional validation
reports that we've performed either with
additional with other laboratories and
then we have our equipment and a few
state testing facilities that are
undergoing evaluation either previously
or currently
and that this is the Hogan here I think
a useful thing just to take away from
this is that this concept of false
positives I think you're one steps back
and treats it as a exercise and an
actual experimental analysis it's in
fact discordance discordance between
that which is seen from a nucleic acid
test versus that which is seen by
culture and if I think they're
especially and we're very often where
such discordance is seen it's
particularly in the case of fungal
analysis and I think that may not be an
accident given the fact that funghi are
notoriously difficult to culture
generally speaking and specifically so I
think one needs I think that the field
we need to revisit the the idea that
this broadly as has been done another
field as to the the nature of the the
information obtained by plate culture
and by a nucleic acid test
Thank You dr. Hogan and thank you dr.
catchman for your time today
now before we go I do want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions we did have
quite a few questions we were unable to
answer and as a reminder for those that
are submitted during the on-demand
period those will be addressed by dr.
Hogan and dr. catchman via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration I'd like to once again
thank dr. Michael Hogan and dr. Ben
catchman for their time today we'd also
like to thank lab rats and our sponsors
pathogen GX for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand and labret swil alert
you via email when it is available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event that's all for
now and we hope to see you again soon
have a great day